bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce dimanche nous ferons
le point sur la colère des marins
pêcheurs qui s'étend sur l'ensemble de
la façade atlantique de nombreux ports
bloqués l'enjeu le prix du gazole qui
s'affolent le ministre de la pêche
michel barnier recevra mercredi les
représentants de la profession
la colère également en chine où les
survivants sont à la recherche de leurs
enfants
le tremblement de terre s'est déroulée
en pleine journée a dévasté des
centaines d'écoles et donc toucher des
milliers d'enfants
les parents réclament une des enquêtes
sur ces bâtiments qui n'ont pas résisté
au séisme
une question de société qui fait écho à
la journée mondiale de lutte contre
l'homophobie l'âge discriminations
existent toujours par exemple travail
mais également au sein même les familles
dès lors que faire
les enfants rejetés blessés trouvent
refuge vous le verrez dans un sens qui
les aide à retrouver un équilibre
c'est le témoignage de ce dimanche soir
la france du football a trouvé son
champion et hier soir septième titre
consécutif pour fixer
paris en revanche est sauvé et c'est
lens qui est tombé ambiance hier soir et
nous reviendrons également sur la
première liste des 30 joueurs
communiquée par raymond domenech pour
l'euro l'absence s'appelle david
trezeguet
enfin cinéma c'est l'événement ce soir à
cannes c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
journal se fait également depuis la
croisette ce soir toute l'équipe d'
indiana jones présente ce dimanche le
quatrième volet de la saga
près de vingt ans après le dernier
épisode la magie est elle toujours
intact avec nous à la fin de cette
édition trois invités exceptionnels
steven spielberg harrison ford et kate
blanchette
voilà pour les titres on se retrouve
tout à l'heure mais pour le moment
l'essentiel de l'actualité c'est avec
olivier galzi bonsoir olivier et à tout
à l'heure
bonsoir laurent merci à tout à l'heure
bonsoir à tous on commence d'abord avec
la colère des pêcheurs la hausse du prix
du gazole fait tache d'huile si l'on
peut dire de la vendée et la loire
atlantique plusieurs ports étaient
bloqués aujourd'hui encore le mouvement
pourrait s'étendre dès demain il faut
dire que pour la profession le système
est devenu absurde les mauvais jours les
marins doivent même payer pour aller
travailler
reportage à la rochelle arnaud compte
fabien tormos
trois jours après les premiers barrages
le mouvement se durcit déjà un symbole
les marins pêcheurs en colère contre le
prix du gasoil s'attaque maintenant aux
dépôts de carburant ce soir ils
dormiront la médiévale le sacrifier
comme les mineurs il ya 40 ans on va pas
quelques kilomètres plus loin le port de
pêche de la rochelle a des allures de
cimetière pour bateaux plus aucun marin
ne sort en mer et ce n'est pas moins
rentables pascal pêcheur depuis 30 ans
naviguent à crédit sur ce chalutier
vieux de 24 ans voilà bah alors c'est
mon bateau comme vous lisez germanique
que moi j'ai racheté il ya maintenant
huit ans emmerson qui peuplent une dix
ans maintenant la payer comme son patron
pierre masclau n'a pas de salaire fixe
c'est la règle dans le métier avec le
prix du gasoil à 70 centimes le litre
contre 35 en novembre les bulletins de
salaire donne aujourd'hui le mal de mer
pour un peu on pèche pas grand chose que
ça se vendent mal et qu'on ait consommé
beaucoup de gasoil faut quand même
failli bien payer le gasoil et comme le
gasoil est payé en partie par l'armement
est en partie par les bateaux arrivent à
se retrouver avec des payes négative
payer pour travailler
les pêcheurs ne veulent pas que cela
devienne une habitude alors ils sortent
en mer quelle que soit la météo et
limite l'entretien des navires
je vois maintenant la peinture l'a fait
le moins en moins qui de bosses des
matches comme ça on redresse pas tout de
suite le moteur ont fait le strict
minimum et les vidanges et puisqu'ils à
faire un boisé tôt ce soir à la rochelle
les ports de pêche et de plaisance sont
toujours bloqués les pêcheurs qui seront
reçus mercredi par michel barnier ne
veulent plus entendre parler de
promesses mais exige des mesures
concrètes et puis en charente maritime
les pêcheurs ont à nouveau décidé
aujourd'hui de bloquer le pont qui mène
à l'île d'oléron
cette opération devrait durer jusqu'à
mercredi date à laquelle le ministre de
la pêche michel barnier doit préciser le
plan daide du gouvernement on l'a appris
tout à l'heure les recherches en mer
pour retrouver le patron d'un chalutier
du finistère ont été suspendus
d'importants moyens de secours avaient
pourtant été mobilisés
son équipage a constaté sa disparition
hier soir au large de l'île de sein
alors qu'il était resté seul sur le pont
le bras de fer se poursuit entre les
enseignants et le gouvernement
le principal syndicat avait appelé à
manifester aujourd'hui à paris pour
protester contre les suppressions de
postes prévues pour la rentrée entre
20000 et 45000 personnes selon les
sources ont répondu à l'appel
estelle colin david fossard le mouvement
lycéen terminé les enseignants prennent
la relève
toujours les mêmes revendications et un
slogan récurrent
une fois encore dialogue de sourds entre
enseignants et gouvernement ce qu'on
veut bosser l'été pour ça le
gouvernement veut retarder premier chef
après avoir décidé jeudi les professeurs
les plus mécontents repartent pour trois
nouvelles manifestations
rien que cette semaine je n'ai comme une
véritable provocation détourner le sujet
et non réponse au personnel de
et si la guerre fait rage
elle ne concerne pas seulement les
suppressions de postes mais aussi le
fameux service minimum dans les écoles
les parents ils sont pas pour l'heure un
service minimum les parents ils sont
inquiets de l'école toute l'année or si
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça qu'on nous
proposons aux propos tenus supprimés en
trois ans 85000 emplois et nous nous
proposer quelques jours de grève des
jardiniers des métros des gardes
champêtres vous regardez nos enfants
jean fiche de ça c'est pas notre
problème
entre deux marches fait don jeudi et
d'aujourd'hui
la plupart des organisations syndicales
se retrouveront demain pour décider de
la suite de leur mouvement
le ministre de l'éducation xavier darcos
a fait savoir tout à l'heure que quelle
que soit la taille des manifestations il
excluait tout retrait des projets de
réformes
et pendant ce temps là le gouvernement
était en séminaire de médicale tous les
ministres ainsi que les secrétaires
d'état étaient conviés au programme
finances publiques et réforme de l'état
autrement dit les deux gros chantiers à
venir françois fillon souhaité dresser
la feuille de route comme on dit de son
gouvernement pour le second semestre
dans les côtes les derniers chiffres de
l'insee sur la croissance en 2007 et au
premier trimestre 2008 montre que cette
politique de réforme commence à produire
ses fruits
notre objectif reste inchangé nous
voulons atteindre l'équilibré des
finances publiques en 2012
et dès 2009 nous nous sommes fixés un
objectif absolu un déficit limité à 2%
du produit intérieur brut
et puis réunion de travail aussi à
gauche pour les amis de dominique
strauss kahn qu'en l'absence de celui-ci
150 d'entre eux environ se sont
rassemblées dans une université
parisienne après l annonce de la
candidature de ségolène royal à la
direction du parti socialiste ils ont
décidé d'apporter eux aussi une
contribution comme on dit au congrès de
novembre elle sera présentée par pierre
moscovici la chine ouvre ses portes au
compte gouttes aux secouristes étrangers
une équipe britannique a été refusé
aujourd'hui elle a dû rebrousser chemin
avec son matériel
une situation d'autant plus frustrante
que sur les lieux du séisme on retrouve
encore des survivants
deux personnes ont pu être sauvées
aujourd'hui contre 63 hier autant dire
que ce sont probablement les dernières
heures d'espoir pour les familles à la
recherche de leurs proches
et dans ce contexte on peut le
comprendre elles sont de plus en plus
nombreuses à exprimer leur colère colère
notamment contre les fonctionnaires qui
ont autorisé la construction d'écoles
avec des matériaux rabais dès la
première secousse on estime que 7 mille
bâtiments scolaires se sont effondrés
comme des châteaux de cartes
philippe rochot il est 15h en chine
quand le tremblement de terre de
magnitude 7,9 secoue la province du
sichuan où des milliers d'enfants sont
en classe
caché sous les tables avec le portable
ils filmeront même la destruction de
leur école mais ils seront aussi les
principales victimes
terrible instants pour les parents
identifier les corps dégagés des
décombres
je père d'une fillette disparue n'aura
pas même la consolation de retrouver le
corps
juste une fois
qu'importe si c'est difficile de leur
trouver une perte immense dans un pays
où l'assurance vieillesse n'existe guère
ces familles comptaient sur leurs
enfants
or avec la politique de l'enfant unique
les couples ne peuvent pas avoir plus
d'un enfant à la ville et de à la
campagne
les écoles se sont effondrés comme des
châteaux de cartes alors que d'autres
bâtiments ont tenu les habitants
accusent de pouvoir locales d'avoir
détourné l'argent est utilisé des
matériaux de mauvaise qualité
ce bâtiment était déjà on l'a dit au
gouvernement local mais on nous a
répondu qu'il n'y avait assez d'argent
pour reconstruire une école avec les
familles il va trouver les responsables
la nouvelle chine a poussé trop vite
seuls les bâtiments qui dépasse une
dizaine d'étagés répondent aux normes
antisismiques
or cette région pauvre du sichuan est
particulièrement vulnérable aux
tremblements de terre et le pouvoir
politique le savait oui ce tremblement
de terre a bien sûr relégué au second
plan ce qui devait être l'événement
majeur ce mois ci en chine
je veux parler du parcours de la flamme
olympique il se poursuit mais dans une
atmosphère vous le voyez quasi
surréaliste silence et tête baissée
rythme désormais son passage le relais
sera d'ailleurs suspendu dès demain
pendant les trois jours de deuil
national en italie la situation des
ordures ménagères à naples vire au chaos
excédés et des habitants de la ville ont
érigé aujourd'hui de véritables
barricades de détritus l'armée a même dû
intervenir et la veille la vieille ville
est désormais touché à la proche de la
saison touristique on est loin vous
allez le voir de la mandoline et des
nappes à carreaux correspondance car
inkomazi cette fois c'est l'armée qui
est appelé à la rescousse des habitants
prennent pour cible des pompiers à coups
de sac poubelle cette napolitaine hurle
mais traite quelque chose aller chercher
la police des actes de rébellion qui en
disent long sur l'exaspération des
napolitains
voilà des semaines qu'aucune ordures n'a
été ramassés et danse à dire pourtant
habitué au désordre qu'on parle cette
fois dans le tiers-monde s'est réveillée
sachez le si c'est le terme ont même
pire la nuit dernière les pompiers ont
battu leur record 84 intervention pour
éteindre des incendies qui reprennent de
plus belle car la chaleur et l'odeur
sont si fortes que les habitants n'ont
pas depuis 48 heures il met le feu aux
ordures même ampleur pour dc a publié un
bulletin d'alert entre les rats et la
dioxine la santé publique et le menacer
on a des enfants il ya un risque de
choléra et de 10 ans le monde doit
savoir ce que nos institutions pour nous
rien on est abandonné les professionnels
du tourisme aussi prennent peur
six cent cinquante mille clients de mon
nom et de l'image de marque de la ville
et pour le moigne et crade
la situation semble bloquée les
décharges de la région sont toutes
saturées sur les trottoirs de naples
4000 tonnes de déchets attendent une
éventuelle mira l'état d'urgence est
telle que le président de la région de
nabeul pourtant très marqué à gauche
tend la main à silvio berlusconi le chef
du gouvernement est attendu et il ne
devra pas décevoir les napolitains une
histoire maintenant une histoire qui ont
dit long sur les dangers d'internet pour
les plus jeunes
aux etats unis une adolescente de 13 ans
s'est pendu par dépit amoureux sont
jeunes fiancés étaient virtuels elle ne
l'avait jamais rencontré et n'a donc
jamais su qu'il s'agissait en fait de la
merde une ses camarades qui la
manipulent et psychologiquement cette
dernière vient d'être inculpé par la
justice américaine elle risque 20 ans de
prison
aurélia guilmain mégane avait 13 ans une
jeune fille fragile qui depuis quelques
semaines pensait s'être fait un nouvel
ami sur internet mais josh n'a en fait
jamais existé un personnage créé de
toutes pièces par une mère de famille de
49 ans qui de cette maison bien soigné
attendu un véritable piège à
l'adolescente niçoise théo ça devait
être un jeu et ça a eu des conséquences
dévastatrices
elle doit les assumer et j'espère
qu'avec les chefs d'inculpation hedayat
contre elle elle va prendre la peine
maximale de prison
lori drew explique aujourd'hui qu'elle
voulait punir l'adolescente pour des
brimades qu'elle aurait fait subir à sa
fille manipulée harceler mégane s'est
pendu dans sa chambre un jour d'octobre
2006 après ce dernier message reçu sur
son ordinateur
le monde serait meilleur sans toit soit
modifs le reste de ta vie
la justice américaine vient d'inculper
la mère de famille pour complot dans le
but d'infliger une souffrance
émotionnelle à une jeune fille mégane
victime d'une relation totalement
virtuel l'homophobie ne recule plus en
france c'est ce que révèle un rapport
annuel et ce qui frappe quand on le
regarde dans les détails c'est que dans
beaucoup de cas les manifestations
d'homophobie sont le fait d
famille et des proches certains parents
préfèrent même rejeté leurs enfants
plutôt que d'accepter leurs différences
françois jullien pieds noirs
david fossard les insultes résonnent
encore dans la tête de giovanni c'est
pas possible du côté des sétois de
soigner c'est ce n'est pas normal c'est
une maladie ce sont les mots de sa mère
quand il lui a annoncé son homosexualité
il avait 14 ans par les crues je suis
plus rien je suis même pas son fils quoi
déjà que c'était soit avec elle au
départ à présent maintenant c'est clair
ça fait deux trois ans que j'ai pu
nouvel essai papillon j'ai souffert je
ferais je tentais de me suicider
plusieurs fois j'ai trimé de projets dus
à la drogue enfin j'ai tout fait pour
oublier j'ai jamais oublier aujourd'hui
la famille de giovanni c'est celle du
refuge à montpellier une association des
deux jeunes homosexuels de 18 à 25 ans
qui ont fui le domicile familial ici
giovanni bénéficient d'un hébergement et
d'une aide pour trouver un travail
donc au niveau des cv temps l'un des
pauses et d'autre part une taille bien
sûr au sol dans des barres unique en
france l'association leur apporte aussi
un soutien psychologique des problèmes
car 90% des jeunes qui passent par
l'association se sont prostituées
pendant trois ans giovanni n'avait pas
de domicile fixe les hommes ont abusé de
sa fragilité et de sa situation précaire
il ya beaucoup de personnes surtout des
personnes beaucoup plus âgés oui
beaucoup plus âgées qui demandent son
qui propose un hébergement ils disent là
on va t'aider à chercher un travail on
va t'aider
chez jeune a besoin de temps à sortir
voilà mais derrière il faut donner il
faut donner j'ai pas de sou j'ai pas de
revenus réguliers je venais coib as tout
le corps
sur le coup ça donne envie de vomir mais
après après il ya les sous donc on est
content d'avoir les billets quoi le
chantage a pris fin grâce aux quelques
mètres carrés de l'appartement de
l'association plus besoin de se
prostituer contre un loyer mais
l'homophobie de son entourage et d'une
partie de la société pèse encore sur son
homosexualité
enfin j'aurais bien aimé être hétéro ma
mère comme ça moi plus materné aimerait
plus donné à mort et plus
tout ça a pris vous n'auriez peut-être a
vécu tout ça non j'aurais jamais vécu
cent l'année dernière 40 jeunes sont
passés par le refuge la plupart ont
trouvé un logement et un travail
seulement 7 ont renoué avec leurs
familles attention aux arnaques si l'on
vous propose d'investir dans du locatif
en résidences touristiques dans des
zones rurales
renseignez vous bien avant de signer la
loi il est vrai prévoit une
défiscalisation intéressante à condition
que la société qui vous propose la ferme
ne vous laisse pas tomber en rase
campagne c'est le cas de le dire et
c'est ce qui est arrivé à des centaines
de nouveaux propriétaires et julien du
père et arnaud jacques une résidence de
tourisme au coeur du périgord de petites
maisons en bois et surtout un
investissement en béton si jacques
talbot a acheté ici c'est pour la
réduction d'impôt de 25 % du prix et la
récupération de la tva
ça vous a coûté combien tout ça le
package complet c'était 124 mille euros
en échange de cette défiscalisation le
propriétaire mais son appartement à la
location pendant neuf ans le tout géré
par une société d'exploitation
mais voilà au bout de trois ans cette
société lâche tous les propriétaires pas
assez rentable dit elle pour éviter tout
perdre un nouvel exploitant est trouvé
mais à ces conditions nous a proposé
directement -40% sur les loyers vous
n'aviez pas le choix et on n'avait pas
le choix
cet avocat parisien des fonds certains
épargnants floués
ces derniers mois les litiges chaque
humain c'est les dossiers qu'on a pour
l'ensemble d'une résidence la question
c'est de savoir s'il faut faire ces
investissements ou pas la réponse est
non parce que la fiscalité et est
enfermé dans des conditions qui sont
très strictes et elle tombe si on a un
problème avec l'exploitant paris champs
elysées voici le siège d'une de ses
sociétés d'exploitation son patron des
noms suit la présence dans le secteur de
confrères peu sérieux quand les
opérateurs ne sont pas sérieux
ça comporte des risques voire beaucoup
de risques ce marché est ouvert à tout
le monde n'importe qui peut se prétendre
vendeurs de ce type de produit et du
coup vous avez une déréglementation du
marché ou une mauvaise gestion par les
pouvoirs publics du marché dans le
périgord les propriétaires espèrent
maintenant obtenir réparation en justice
maigre consolation pour jacques tu as
beau en attendant il peut tout de même
profité de son appartement
trois semaines par an et de 7 l'ol a
remporté son septième titre consécutif
de champion de france
images ici du trophée exhiber toute à
l'heure encore au balcon de la mairie
c'est presque devenu une habitude pour
les joueurs de l'ol lyon rejoint donc
nantes et monaco panthéon des clubs les
plus titrés dans ce championnat derrière
marseille et saint-etienne
de quoi ton contentez vous voyez la
population lyonnaise qui a fêté ses
héros comme il se doit
il ya eu donc beaucoup de buts hier pour
cette dernière journée de ligue 1 43 ans
tous beaucoup de buts et beaucoup
d'émotion aussi des rires et des larmes
on commence avec celle des ch'tis les
lensois ont finalement hérité du ticket
maudit pour la relégation en ligue 2
florent gautreau patrick the storm comme
un petit air de désolation
entre larmes et crises de nerfs les
supporters lensois ont mal vécu leur
dernière soirée en ligue 1 les valeurs
de lancer le public et tout le public et
des curés qu'on descende en ligue 2 ça
fait chier j'ai des gens qui ne partent
pas en vacances qui font tous les
déplacements par chèque par tous les
temps madame par tour et je vous assure
que c'est des gens ils en veulent aux
janvier malheureusement on a joué notre
saison sur un match
hier soir pendant la rencontre c'était
ville morte et le match de la dernière
chance n'a rien changé
lens n'a pas réussi à battre bordeaux
score final 2 partout bienvenue en ligue
2 lens prend l'ascenseur pour l'étagé
inférieur en compagnie de metz et
strasbourg résultat toulouse et le psg
ce souffle in extremis le paris
saint-germain l'emporta sochaux 2 1
grâce à un doublé de diane et rapide sur
le premier but malin sur le deuxième a
toulouse la délivrance arrive à la 75e
minute le but de sirieix vaut de l'or
direction maintenant le haut du
classement avec le retour des verts en
coupe d'europe 26 ans après
saint-etienne bat monaco 4-0 et arrache
la 5e place qualificative pour la coupe
de l'uefa
dans la série les grands clubs ne
meurent jamais revoilà l'om tout près de
la ligue des champions qualifié son tour
préliminaire après sa victoire 4 3
contre strasbourg avec ou sans nation ne
sait pas encore mais le prodige
marseillais a illuminé la soirée d'une
reprise de volée imparable
marseille 3e bordeaux 2e et lyon encore
premier c'est le podium en haut de gamme
du championnat 2008
lyon a souffert mais les orfèvres
lyonnais ont un nouveau joyau en vitrine
karine à benzema meilleur buteur de la
saison avec 20 réalisations
l'ol remporte son septième titre
consécutif cette saison d'exception sept
ans de bonheur
on est décidément l'actualité du
football était riche aujourd'hui le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
raymond domenech a annoncé sa
présélection en vue de l'euro 2008
elle comporte deux grosses surprises
l'absence de trezeguet et la présence de
l'attaquant stéphanois gomis
pour l'heure la liste comporte trente
noms il y aura donc à l'arrivée sept
malheureux manuel tissier avec des
larmes et en costume ou en maillot bleu
avec le sourire david trezeguet n'est
pas prêt de goûter à nouveau les
émotions de l'équipe de france raymond
domenech a tranché ce matin le buteur
aux 71 sélections ne fait pas partie des
30 joueurs retenus pour préparer l'euro
une demi surprise commises je confirme
ce qui s'est passé ces deux dernières
saisons parce qu'à un moment faut
prendre une décision avec les choses
soient claires le stéphanois bafetimbi
gomis est la seule vraie surprise de
cette présélection 22 ans 16 buts en
ligue 1 cette saison
il intègre une liste dont seuls 18
éléments ici en jaune sont assurés de
partir pour la suisse en raison du
calendrier
domenech n'a pas hésité à faire des
malheureux comme aimé jacquet je pense
que tout le monde se souvienne 98 et des
problèmes que ça a causé
mais ce sourire sur toute l'équipe de
france a été championne du monde cette
année là le marseillais steve mandanda
est en concurrence avec sébastien frey
pour le poste de gardien numéro 3 le
joueur de florence est favori en défense
centrale et niera que deux élus parmi
mexès boumsong squilacci et escudé
chez les milieux de terrain le bordelais
alou diarra al'avantage d'avoir disputé
la finale de la coupe du monde ce sera
lui ou flamini ou nasri enfin il n'y a
qu'une place d'attaquant à prendre les
36 sélections de djibril cissé devrait
lui permettre de passer devant ben arfa
et gomis
les futurs banny connaîtront leur sort
dans dix jours à tignes les lieux du
stage des bleus en altitude
sept joueurs vont tomber de haut les
choses promises choses dues on repart
maintenant à cannes retrouver laurent
delahousse avec ses invités prestigieux
pour l'avant-première d' indiana jones
laurent c'est à vous merci olivier merci
olivier nous sommes donc à cannes avec
trois invités exceptionnels ce soir
steven spielberg kate blanchett harrison
ford pour la sortie d'un film événement
un film culte le quatrième volet d'
indiana jones alors tout d'abord bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
tout d'abord steven spielberg
une question est ce que une journée
comme celle là c'est une journée quand
même comme les autres un peu autant de
succès la sortie d'un film ici à cannes
est ce qu'il ya un petit peu de stress
tout de même en vous vous savez j'ai
toujours un peu de stress quand on sort
un film où que ce soit mais quand c'est
à cannes évidemment lorsque le monde
entier a les yeux rivés sur cannes
évidemment quand tout le monde pense ne
parle que de cela il ya une pression
extraordinaire c'est clair mais on ne
peut rien y faire
parce que le film est terminé maintenant
c'est le vôtre
à vous de jouer on a peur de quoi on a
peur que que finalement les gens soient
déçus après une telle série intel saga
non j'ai pas peur de ça du tout
moi je suis très content de savoir que
les gens vont voir le feu ce film ça
fait longtemps qu'il attendait moi ce
qui me passionne c'est que
justement il ya des familles entières de
gens qui vont pouvoir aller voir ce film
après avoir vu l'arche perdue le temple
maudit la dernière croisade ils vont
enfin les voir ce quatrième volet alors
vous avez réussi quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel garder le secret à l'heure
à l'époque d'internet sur ce film
personne ne sait rien et c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on va véritablement
découvrir cette histoire comment vous
avez réalisé ce ce terrible
le fait que personne ne soit au courant
de ce scénario le seul secret que j'ai
gardées c'est que je n'ai pas montré le
scénario aux acteurs c'est tout
je n'ai toujours pas lui non non moi
j'ai lu le script alors on va regarder
un petit peu à quoi ressemble la journée
votre journée une journée assez
exceptionnel et puis on va se retrouver
juste après ce reportage de marie jo
jours rude journée pour le rush illberg
est-il vite l'aiment les journalistes
c'est une autre affaire ce n'est pas
évident de revenir 19 ans plus tard avec
indiana héros culte certes mais de 65
ans aujourd'hui
arrivé à la conférence de presse où
protection spielberg et détendue comment
vous vous sentez plutôt bien suivi de
kate blanchet cela méchant du film et
d'un allison ford toujours aussi
séduisant et en forme
et c'est là qu'on voit des journalistes
de venir groupe i devant indie des
générations versé par une trilogie
commencée en 1981 et qui a engrangé plus
d'un milliard de recettes mondiales en
salle sachez que dans ce nouvel opus
l'archéologue aventurier se retrouve en
pleine guerre froide les soviétiques ont
remplacé les nazis dans le rôle des
méchants une dit découvre qu'il a un
fils et ce dernier va même l'aider à
retrouver un crâne de cristal une
relique maya qui a un lien avec les
extraterrestres le reste on vous laisse
la surprise
sortie de la première projection verdict
des journalistes
il a voulu s'inspirer de l'époque des 50
en fait il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui se disait à propos des
extraterrestres je pense qu il était
collé à l'époque c'est un pôle
d'attraction une distraction
on a presque l'impression de déjà à
eurodisney
dans le manège quoi la montagne russe
dans
le train fantôme il ya d'humour
harrison ford a toujours
il a même tenu à réaliser certaines
cascades indy est une valeur sûre steven
spielberg et george lucas ce le
producteur l'ont compris depuis
longtemps entre star wars et indiana
jones et de l'art tout simplement
inventé le concept du block busters le
final gros budget est accro succès alors
voilà à quoi ça ressemble harrison ford
on adore ce type de légende il paraît
que la production vous a fourni l'ancien
panoplie votre costume d'il ya 20 ans il
vous là on vous la livrer chez vous est
ce que c'est une légende ou pas quelque
temps avant de tourner les premiers
plans de ce film tout ce qu'on voulait
c'est que le costume souhaite sur mesure
donc on la refait vous voulez que ce
soit le même on refait le même on a fait
une quarantaine de chapeau je sais plus
combien de vestes etc non gelée remis je
limite ou simplement et les gens vise
ici et là que l'on était inquiet pour
que je rentre encore dans mon costume et
moi ce qui m'inquiétait c'était bien
d'autres choses il faut bien voir que
c'était comme me retrouver un vieil ami
et donc j'avais des attentes très
importante et dès lors que j'ai remis ce
chapeau et remis cette veste
comment dire c'était vraiment un moment
tout à fait délicieux
vous avez retrouvé votre personnage de
manière instantanée dès les premiers
coups de caméras
vous savez steven a bien organisé les
premières scènes on a tourné une
séquence on a commencé par une séquence
qui était d'une présentation le du
personnage dans le film est donc je dois
dire que ça a été vraiment formidable
que de voir stephen manipuler ce moment
est de 2 le petit c'est comme ça et d'en
faire quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'était vraiment quelque chose de très
agréable à voir ça m'a rappelé tous les
très bons souvenirs que j'avais eu à
tourner c'est fini à travailler mais que
steven évidemment ça m'a mis en
condition et après j'ai passé des
moments
inoubliable on avait un programme de 80
jours je travaille et 79 jours
croyez moi tous les jours j'étais ravie
de me lever pour le travail lui seul nom
fait 84,7 justement qu'est ce que ça
représentait pour vous ce mythe dit
diana jones
j'ai adoré ces films j'ai grandi avec
les ai adorés
quand j'étais jeune vivait et j'aurais
voulu être arrêt sur ford
parce que je les fais avec arena là je
n'avais pas eu le rôle mais j'avais eu
le prix de consolation et j'ai eu à
faire la méchante et c'était merveilleux
alors justement cette méchante irina
spall qu une soviétique
elle veut la peau du dr jones c'est bien
dire que celle de beaucoup plus que ma
peau elle veut m'enlever certains
secrets très sympa temps auquel je
voudrais avoir accès et elle fait preuve
de charme évidemment pour m'ont empêché
est belle c'est une combinaison mortelle
alors since plr n'a pas envie de
raconter bien évidemment l'histoire il
faut que les téléspectateurs le découvre
après autant de mystères juste une chose
c'était quoi la difficulté c'était
retrouver le style des presses des
précédents films
ce fait cela la même atmosphère
oui vraiment la difficulté c'était de
faire en sorte que ce film était comme
ce que j'avais fait quand j'étais plus
jeune et je me suis rendu compte au bout
d'un moment que c'était pas tellement
difficile à faire mais qu'il fallait
simplement que
prennent un peu de recul par rapport à
moi-même parce qu'avec les années
j'avais changé ma façon de deux tournées
de travail et la façon dont je tournais
la caméra et quand je faisais quelque
chose d'extraordinaire à l'époque ou non
passer quand j'ai fait quelque chose de
bien je disais toujours à temps on va
garder ça pour le prochain film experts
à d'autres j'étais influencé par les
films précédents et je voulais
absolument avoir une approche tout à
fait différente et essayer justement de
faire en sorte que l'action soit en
dehors de l'action et que la caméra ne
fasse qu accompagner soutenir l'action
et ne soit pas au coeur de cette action
mais je veux dire que effectivement avec
les acteurs que j'avais c'était pas très
difficile alors je vois qu'on vienne sur
également une légende faux faux faux la
terre cette légende est ce que c'est
vous harrison ford ou est ce que c'est
vous steven spielberg dans le premiers
aventuriers de l'arche perdue qui a eu
cette idée justement de cette séquence
avec cet homme avec le sabre et puis
harrison ford dégaine son pistolet et
tire c'est de vous et c'est de lui on en
parlait hier soir justement et c'est une
histoire qu'on peut raconter
en fait on avait tourné une séquence
assez longue avec karine ardennes qui
étaient kidnappés et s'il y avait moi
j'étais à revin fouet j'étais contre 5
méchant et puis ensuite la séquence
suivante était censé être une
confrontation avec ce type qui tient
l'épée et donc steven lui avait créé une
séquence qu'il aurait fallu pour
laquelle il aurait fallu trois jours de
tournage à tout le moins c'est unique
finalement il y avait c'était donc assez
plu finale entre le fouet et l'épée et
il ya pas mal de gens sur scène sur le
pendant le tournage qui était conscient
de tout cela et qui attend j'y reviens
cette histoire mais il m'a fallu au
moins une heure pour aller au travail ce
matin mais quand je suis arrivé au
travail j'étais vraiment déterminé à
faire une proposition à steven et donc
j'allais le voir et je lui dis à temps
est-ce qu'on va on va butter ce mec
et puis voilà on comme ça on sera
tranquille il m'a dit exactement la même
chose donc plus ça a duré une heure on a
fait on a fait quatre prises et ça a été
réglé en deux minutes et après c'était
réglé
est ce que maintenant on en a vu un deux
trois quatre
tout le monde se pose la question est ce
qu'il y aura à cinquième est ce qu'il
faudra attendre 20 ans et d'ailleurs
pourquoi on a autant attendu pourquoi 20
ans à cause de lui ou à cause d'eux au
yen un peu difficile pour moi c'est fini
donc je suis j'ai une boule et enfin
sortir dit il et j'ai vu la lumière au
bout du tunnel et je me suis dit qu'il
fallait que je reviens dans la réalité
mais avant ça harrison aux oscars c'est
lui qui m'a permis d'avoir mon premier
oscar pour la liste de schindler il ya
quelques années et à ce moment là il m'a
dit eh bien moi je suis tout à fait
disposé à remettre la casquette dynegy
annonce vraiment et ça c'était quatre
ans simplement après avoir fini le
troisième film le dernier
il m'a dit d'accord et donc les gens ont
commencé à dire battre harrison est
d'accord pour en faire une
pour faire un autre volet donc je dis
d'accord donc on a continué on a essayé
de trouver le bon scénario ne voulais
pas décevoir les gens évidemment donc
une jacqueline dizaine d'années pour
trouver la bonne le bon scénario ensuite
on s'est mis d'accord sur quelque chose
et puis
je suis sorti un petit peu ces périodes
un peu sombre je faisais des films peu
et noir et c'est donc là je c'est un peu
une récréation pour moi que de refaire
un film je reviens à ma question
un numéro 5 ou pas disponible mais kane
je sais pas je ne sais pas si elle
pourra les vendre
ça dépend de vous vraiment c'était pas
simplement que harrison voulait
reprendre son fouet et son chapeau
c'était une idée vraiment qu'ils nous
intéressait qui nous taraudaient plus
farison georges ou moins et donc on
voulait vraiment remettre les relancer
une situation tout à fait nouvelle et si
on trouve un nouveau on a trouvé un
nouveau scénario si les gens ont envie
de voir arriver dans un autre contexte
pourquoi pas harrison ford
juste un conseil pour les jeunes acteurs
qui commencent leur carrière et ce qu'il
faut un petit peu on va dire en france
on dit galéré avant de de commencer vous
allaitez charpentier à hollywood à un
moment donné est-ce qu'il faut quelques
échecs avant de connaître le succès
c'est le conseil que je pourrais donner
c'est que le lien éléments de ma
personnalité qui m'a beaucoup aidé dans
ma carrière
au fil des ans alors que j'essayais de
2,2 de faire mon trou dans ce métier
c'est de comprendre qu'il faut faire
preuve de ténacité c'est ça qui compte
c'est tout ce qui compte il faut que
vous vous battiez jusqu'au bout que ce
soit à l'école et plus tard il ya
beaucoup de gens qui abandonneraient
assez rapidement mais ceux qui n'ont pas
tout laisser tomber qui ceux qui n'ont
pas jeté l'épongé bien ce sont eux qui
s'en sortent donc pour moi franchement
c'est une question de maintien de mes
ambitions pas de mes rêves de mes
ambitions vraiment s'en tenir à ses
ambitions vouloir faire du boulot de
qualité ça c'est ça qui m'a un qui m'a
motivé au cours des années un dernier
mot steven spielberg vous avez
lisez nos rêves d'enfants pendant toutes
ces années un dernier mot sur la
nouvelle aventure qui arrive
tintin c'est ça oui la prochaine
aventure de ma vie sera la production
dans un film de la bande dessinée de
hergé tintin effectivement et ça c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait nouveau il
va me falloir deux ans et demi pour
faire ce film d'animation est donc avec
le co producteur
eh bien nous n'avons pas prévu de sortir
ce film avant 2010 ou 2011 il y aura
peut-être d'autres films qui sortiront
avant tintin peut-être retrouvera-t-on
ici d'ailleurs pour en parler je
l'espère en tout cas merci beaucoup on
attendra effectivement tintin et surtout
le quatrième volet d' indiana jones qui
sort en france
effectivement mercredi merci à tous les
trois c'est la fin de ce journal on va
se quitter sur cette image puisque cette
interview a été réalisée
justement au cours de cette journée sur
les images de la montée des marches
votre montée des marches ce soir pour ce
film le quatrième volet de la saga
indiana jones
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un journal cette fois ci à paris tout de
suite maintenant c'est la météo
et puis ce soir un film le cinéma c'est
swimming pool merci passer une très très
belle soirée sur france 2
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 pourrait faire
votre soirée